we have seen a historic decline in crime
all through the 1990s it has not yet in
a very significant way picked up with
this recession we've seen and this is
very important for people to realize
crime rates in some cases drop more
steeply in states that have not
incarcerated such huge portions of their
population you know one of the steepest
declines has been in New York City which
has sent a whole lot of people to jail
on Rockefeller drug laws and so on but
nothing like the south and yet crime in
New York has fallen much more steeply
than in Houston or Dallas so the crime
drop is a great riddle for social
scientists to figure out but critically
at least I think it's important for
people to know that the massive growth
of incarceration isn't we think not one
of the largest determining factors in
decreasing that crime incarceration has
been going up straight since the 1970s
in some of the periods crime restoration
has been going up crime has been going
up other times down but there's not a
clear correlation between incarceration
and protecting the public and in fact
one of the statistics you would think
you would have gotten if you believe
even in a kind of weak version of
deterrence you would think that all of
these harsher penalties would at least
deter some of the people who know the
criminal justice system best criminals
and former prisoners from committing
crimes because they do become even if
there are levels of educational
attainment or somewhat limited through
being kind of cranked through the
criminal justice system they learn a lot
of the criminal law and they know the
penalties are very harsh
so if deterrence were to work and if
affected if imprisonment was an
effective way of dealing with crime you
would think that recidivism rates in the
United States would be lower now than
they were when the prison boom began
when penalties were compared ibly more
mild instead the opposite has occurred
recidivism rates have gone up and you
know one more piece of evidence that
shows this this experiment experiment
and mass incarceration has been on the
one hand a total failure in terms of
in terms of protecting the public on the
other hand a catastrophe for the weakest
members of our the most vulnerable
members of our society
including those who are more victimized
by crimes that's also in the poor in the
poor neighborhoods it hasn't helped them
in any way their people are getting
shipped off to rural prisons and then
those rural prisons are getting the
census money and so on and they're still
suffering higher rates of crime so it's
uh it's a mess I'm afraid
people have tried
it's it's harder to do than people have
claimed some economists have said well
even if you are spending $50,000 a year
to lock someone up as is the price in
California where the corrections
officers are well paid because that
person you're putting behind bars would
have committed X number of crimes then
you're actually saving money but those
studies kind of fall apart for a whole
series of reasons they're based on kind
of surveys with certain classes of
criminals that don't correlate very well
to who's actually in prison they don't
take into account the ways that crime
can't just be thought of as a
subtraction from the economy I mean as
as strange as it sounds if I steal $100
from you that doesn't decrease the GDP
of the United States it just means I
have $100 to spend and generate economic
activity and you don't so it's not a
subtraction it's not a costs a society's
a cost to you it's not a cost to society
so those those studies don't hold up
very well I mean it's true that I think
you know that incarceration is not
something we're going to be able to get
rid of in entirely there are people who
are extremely dangerous a very small a
very small portion it's important to
realize we think that prison beds are
filled with dangerous sexual predators
and and armed robbers and serial killers
because that's how it seems watching the
nightly news that's not the case most
most people going into prison are
nonviolent offenders in any given year
and most of them are drug offenders or
are you know hooked on alcohol and and
so on